We've got a voicemail number two, one nine
two, David P. today's voicemail is a very
practical question about the democratic primary
I David. So now that Bernie Sanders is one,
the first couple of primaries and caucuses
and he pulling, well going into super Tuesday,
uh, mathematically speaking, what's the fastest
way you could wrap this up and what's the
earliest we could know who the nominee is
going to be presuming that it will be Bernie,
which hopefully it will be.
So listen, I don't if the, if, if, let me
see how to word this. If the nominee is going
to be Bernie, we are not going to know that
very soon. The things that we could know soon
are, and I really think we'll know by super
Tuesday, does anybody really have a path to
half of the delegates before the convention
or is it going to be a brokered contested
or maybe a better term is negotiated? Convention
contested implies something different, but
will it be a negotiated convention? We will
probably know that by midnight on Tuesday
if Bernie is going to get half of the delegates
from primaries from winning primaries. I think
we're not going to know for a while, particularly
once Michael Bloomberg wins some delegates
on Tuesday, it will become even more split.
So it's going to be a, it's going to be awhile.
We've got a great bonus vote show for you
today. We will talk about the death of Hosni
Mubarak, the Egyptian strong man who was undone
by the Arab spring. We will also talk about
the U S losing the toilet race. It's a weird
story, but irrelevant one. And we will also
talk about how there has been a spike in the
number of seniors, uh, using cannabis edibles
and also smoking pot. What is behind it? What
does it mean? All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show, grab a memory
[inaudible] or become a patron to get instant
access. Otherwise, as sad as it is, we will
speak to you next tomorrow, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].